We're on our way to look for Uman. We're
just going to see, man, if we can find
Shik Uman because he says he's been
looking for us. He said he's been
calling us out. He said that he'll
debate us in person. He said that he'll,
you know, fly us out. Never did, never
flew us out. Said he'll pay for our
expenses. Never paid. Went silent on
Twitter when we hit him up. Sean Kelly
told him that he he could debate me on
his podcast. Um man declined to debate
me on Shan Kelly's podcast, but he
agreed to debate Captain Cesarak,
though. Isn't that interesting? He'll
debate a Hebrew Israelite, but he won't
debate me. He won't debate David Wood.
He won't debate inspiring philosophy. He
won't debate Sam Shimone. What's going
on? But pretending like he really wants
to debate. Okay, here's your tent. There
it is. Here's the tent. Jesus is a
Muslim. I got a question about that.
Going to make this statement real quick.
Salam,
what's up, bro?
>> Hey, how you doing, man?
>> Is Usmar coming today? No.
>> Usman shar.
>> Why not? He said that he would he was
here and ready to debate. Like was he he
was streaming yesterday?
>> I think he was streaming though. Didn't
he invite you, David Wood?
>> Well, he said that he would fly us out
and he never did. Yeah. He said that he
would fly us out to Florida to go have a
conversation in person with the dean uh
at the dean show. And
>> I'm not.
>> Maybe you call him cuz uh
>> call who?
>> So I know he's here. I know he's in
town.
>> So
>> he's not in town.
>> He's not in town. So So he's Where was
he streaming from?
>> I don't know. He wasn't streaming from
here.
>> He's streaming from here. He's home.
>> No. No.
>> He said cuz he said that he would not be
flying on the 17th. He said he'd be
back. So that's why he was able to
stream though.
>> Oh, I I Interesting.
>> I said you could have went on to the
stream.
>> Okay.
>> And you could have talked and did
whatever you want to do, right?
>> Why Why would I go on a stream when I
can meet him in person? And he said that
he would debate in person. Yeah. So if
we if we have an agreement to meet in
person, why would I go on a stream? If
he agreed to talk to me in person, why
would I go on a stream when that's not
what we agreed to? I'm not your arbiter.
>> Exactly.
>> I am not his legal representative.
>> But would you would you would you agree
that would you agree?
>> Trying to make a clip.
>> Would you agree that he's being
dishonest?
Everyone's enjoying this. Trust me.
>> I know they're enjoying it. It's not
going to benefit you, right?
>> It is. It's showing that one chick is a
coward. He's nowhere to be found. We're
in it.
>> We're in this city.
>> You're going to sit here and just try
and talk about someone behind their
back? I'm not
>> What do you mean behind their back? It's
on a stream. I know. Let me do it this
way.
>> You're a coward. You're a coward. You
won't show up.
>> You haven't been here since we destroyed
you. And there's a reason why you won't
come debate us.
>> Say whatever you want to say. You can go
say it anywhere else.
>> I want to say it in front of his right
here. Say it right here cuz this is his
this is his establishment organ. This is
an organization
>> ran by
>> that he is a volunteer of
>> volunteer.
>> It is not his organization. Is he a
leader?
>> He isn't on the list of leaders. He
isn't someone that is legally bound to
it. He's a volunteer.
>> So to be clear, you're saying you're
saying he is a volunteer. Everyone here
is a volunteer.
>> Who's the who's the face of One Message
Foundation? Michelle, be honest.
>> So who the face of it is? Who's doing
what behind the scenes? There's many
people doing stuff. Who's the face?
>> But right now, all you need to do is
when there is a chance because there was
a chance yesterday and there was a
chance before
>> instead of joining you claim to be sick.
I me being sick had nothing to do with
being on the jo
>> why I didn't join the stream the first
time is Michelle is because let me tell
you I just listened to you the reason
why I didn't join the stream is because
Uman agreed to fly me he didn't we
didn't ask he hit Nick up and and asked
for me and him and said that he will pay
us pay for our expenses fly us out and
debate in person so why would I join
join a stream when he changes the
stipulations when he promised that he
would pay for me to fly out to debate in
person. So guess what I did? I said,
"You know what? I won't join a stream.
What I'll do is I'll come from Vegas.
I'll drive 5 hours. I'll come to San
Diego where I know his booth is and say,
"Where you at,
>> Usman?"
>> So where is he?
>> Called him up.
>> That's why I didn't join the stream. And
I won't join the stream until he debates
in person like you promised.
>> I'm not his orbiter. I am not the guy
mating the making the meetings
>> and you coming out making a scene trying
to make a clip.
>> Oh no, this is this people like it.
>> There's no trying about it.
>> But I know for a fact that you are being
disingenuous
>> in what way?
>> In many ways like I said like I said
>> you can't Michelle you can't accuse me.
>> You can't accuse me and then not give me
You said everything you said is based on
evidence. So what's the evidence that
you give that I'm disingenuous? Like I
said, I don't have conversations with
you, bud.
>> No, but you make
>> I don't you make claims.
>> Why not?
>> I don't.
>> But you you just said that everything
you have is based on evidence.
>> Alhamdulillah.
>> So when you put up a thing says Jesus is
a Muslim or you guys have the little
sign. Where's the little sign that says
ask a Muslim anything? Ask a Muslim a
question.
>> We come here. There's 4,500 people
wanting to know why you guys say Jesus
is a Muslim. Why is the Quran the word
of God?
>> Allah.
>> Because you agree with the Shia.
>> So everything that [laughter] we believe
is based on evidence.
>> All right. But what's the evidence that
Jesus
>> evidence the evidence that Jesus peace
and blessing be upon him is a Muslim is
that Allah mentioned it the prophet
explained it
>> and and the claims that are in there we
can verify that someone said it
>> the evidence based upon the miracles we
accept as our faith
>> I got you.
>> So right now like I mentioned more than
once I'm not going to sit here and give
you content
>> but you're we're just having a
conversation man give you content.
>> Okay I'll at least respond to what you
said. Okay. So if you're saying
>> I can respond over there. I'm not if if
you're going to say m I'll just talk
this but I'm talking to you right here.
>> If you're going to say m that we know
that Jesus is a Muslim because Allah
subhana wa ta'ala said so.
>> That's just a claim bro. It's not
evidence. If you say that everything
that you have is based on evidence that
means that you can prove to me that what
Allah is saying is true. So what is the
evidence that you have Michel or any da
guy? What's the evidence that you have
that when we look here and it says Jesus
is a Muslim? What evidence do you have?
Matter of fact, hold on a second. You
You have say You have things saying that
of what Jesus said.
>> What What evidence do you have of what
Jesus said?
>> Submitted to Allah. That's your book,
sister.
>> Oh, you We don't We don't
>> You agree with the
>> He's a Sunni Muslim. You don't think
he's a Muslim?
>> We don't want to discuss that.
>> Oh, no. You don't want to discuss it.
>> He's a Muslim. He's a Muslim. He's
Muslim. You're a Muslim.
>> You think Sunnis are Muslim?
>> He say testimony of faith.
>> Is he a Muslim, brother? Yes.
>> Is he a Muslim? So everything on the
side of the tent is from the Quran.
>> It's from the Quran based on what
though?
>> From the Quran.
>> How do you know that Jesus said how you
know the Quran is getting that right?
>> I just told you that I'm not going to
have a conversation. [laughter] It's a
circular.
>> So look, the problem is this uh
Michelle, when you're when the Quran is
saying Jesus said something, right? If
it's saying Jesus said something, this
is talking about somebody that's 600
years before. So you got to go ahead and
talk about them
>> to come talk to people at the park.
>> What did he say? I said you left all of
the people that have followers online
and you came to talk to people.
>> What do you mean left? What do you mean
left the people?
>> You left Libyaniano already destroyed
them twice. Even Even Jake metaphysician
says I destroyed them.
>> You left every single person that has a
following online
>> to come to talk to so-called nobodies
because you're not a nobody to me.
>> We don't have followings.
>> Michelle, it's not about you talking to.
>> It doesn't matter to me.
>> You're doing that. You're doing that,
right? Because you're starred for
content that much.
>> I'm starving. How many How many are
watching now?
>> You were They were on for 3 hours.
>> So almost 5,000 people. I'm starving for
I'm star I'm starving for content, guys.
I'm starving. That's the point. You
would You could have had more if you
That's your objective, right? You could
have done it last night. 3 hours they
were online.
>> So why didn't they Why didn't they come
here?
>> 3 hours.
>> Why didn't they come here? Yeah, you're
right. Cuz I'm I'm here in person. Why
won't he come in person?
>> So right now. Right now. Why won't he
come in person?
>> Shehman is traveling.
>> Where?
>> He's across the country.
>> No, he's not. He's right here in Cali.
He said that we look this is this is how
we know because IP
>> I know for a fact he's he's not here.
>> He's traveling. He's
>> see. No, no, he's right here. He was at
his crib streaming for 3 hours. And so
when he and I told him I'm going to be
out here on the 17th radio silence.
>> You were invited to his crib, right?
>> No, I wasn't invited to his house.
>> You was never invited to his house?
>> No. Okay. So, he was in his crib, right?
>> But not the crib that was here.
>> What do you mean not the crib that was
here?
>> He was here. He was
>> He was here in San Diego.
>> He wasn't here. He was at his home, but
he has multiple
>> in San Diego, right?
>> No, not in San Diego.
>> So, you're telling me that last night he
was not a lie? I'm telling you.
>> Now, you've lied to me so many times,
bro.
>> I've never lied to you once.
>> Yes, you have.
>> You told me that I that I take things
out of context. That's a lie.
>> No, it's not a It's not a lie. Uh,
Avery,
>> it is. If you're saying that I take
things out of context and you can't
provide me how I do that, you're you're
slandering me. That's a lie, bro.
>> So, you've taken stuff multiple times
out of context.
>> Give me one.
>> But I'm not going to sit here and debate
with you over it. Right. You ask me why
this is written. I told you because it's
from the Quran.
>> If you tell me,
>> did Jesus submit himself to God? Did
Jesus submit himself to the father
according to your belief?
>> He did.
>> Being a submitter is someone who is a
Muslim. We as Muslims believe that all
of the prophets of Allah
>> came with the same commandments from
that same creator.
>> I got you,
>> right? Commandments to their people. And
those people that followed their prophet
at their time were always called Muslim.
Even the Jews, even the people of Noah,
even the people of Abraham, and you know
this because we've had multiple
conversations.
>> Now, you said to be a Muslim is a
submitter and that's it, right? And so
therefore, because they submit to Jesus
submit to the father
>> time of their prophets.
>> I got you. So my question would be this.
Does it matter who or what they're
submitting to?
>> Allah,
>> right? Can they submit to something that
is a idol or a statue and still be a
Muslim?
>> No.
>> Right. So they have to submit to the
correct view of the true God. Would you
say
>> based on what Allah sends to each
prophet at their time?
>> Okay, that's fair enough.
>> So even the Hindus today, they follow
their scriptures, right? We don't affirm
that what they have came from the
creator, but any goodness in it might be
from a prophet that came to them at a
certain time.
>> Okay. Okay. Interesting. So, so
>> that's why even as Muslims, we don't go
putting bad things on like their
scriptures, the Hindu scriptures, eating
them, burning them.
>> That's fine. So, so let me ask you this
then. Okay. Cuz when you said you asked
me, did Jesus submit to the father?
Right? And I said yes. Right. And you
said okay. So, therefore, he's a Muslim.
So would you say then that when Jesus is
submitting to his father, God his
father, that this affirms that Jesus is
the son of God?
>> Of course not.
>> So then how is he a Muslim subitting to
his father
>> from them cannot be verified as opposed
to what we have in the Quran.
>> But you just verified. No, you just
verified that Jesus submitted to his
father. You said this, not me.
>> Because your understanding of God up in
the heavens,
>> it's not about my my understanding.
>> Call the father. So to give your
understanding what you believe, your
idea. I'm not talking about Michelle.
It's not about my belief.
>> Your idea and belief based on the Bible
is different with a unarian.
>> No worries. That's that has nothing to
do what we're talking about. Listen, if
you're saying we're talking about
whether or not Jesus objectively,
whether you think it or me thinking, it
doesn't matter. Objectively looking at
Jesus and what he believed in practice,
was he a Muslim? Right?
>> Alhamdulillah.
>> So if he if you said
>> according to the truth of what he had
and what he said in the Quran in the
Okay, but you didn't point to what is in
the Bible.
>> But you but you pointed to the Bible.
You see, you said Jesus submitted to the
father
>> about what?
>> Submitting to the father.
>> So you said prove to me how he is from
the Bible.
>> No.
>> No, I didn't.
>> You understand the Bible?
>> But I never I never brought up the
Bible, brother.
>> When I told you we believe what we
believe based on what is in the Quran
explained by the prophet, right? You
didn't accept that.
>> Why not?
>> So you you didn't accept it.
>> I know. Why? Why didn't I? What was the
reason I gave you, brother?
>> You told me that that is not what you
believe in.
>> No, that's not what I said. Listen, I
said the Quran is making a claim, right?
And so what I'm asking for now is
evidence backing up what the Quran is
saying. So I didn't say you got to show
me from the Bible. I didn't say anything
like that. Just what's the evidence that
the Quran is getting
>> clipped, right? Because it's it's live.
I know it's live. So I'm saying later on
when you clip.
>> Okay.
>> Earlier I said why I believe it's the
truth. because it's verifiable and all
of the signs and things that point to it
being truthful is why I accept it as
truth.
>> Fair enough.
>> Let's talk about that.
>> Okay, I'm listening. Go ahead.
>> Okay, so the prophet Noah, peace be upon
him. What would you call him in what you
believe as your religion? He
>> was a Hebrew.
>> He was a Hebrew.
>> Yeah.
>> Noah.
>> How was he a Hebrew?
>> Because he's of the line of Abraham. So
Abraham is a descendant of Noah. So
>> So who was left over after the flood?
>> No. and his children.
>> So Noah and his children according to
you, that's all the people that were
left.
>> Yeah.
>> So his children are Noah,
>> like same lineage, right?
>> Or are they different lineage?
>> His children.
>> Are his children the same lineage? You
just said Noah
>> that Noah is a Hebrew.
>> Yeah.
>> So that means if they're the only ones
according to you, then every You're
asking me about his race, right?
>> Yeah. Initi initially we all come from
if we're all spilling up from Noah, we
all come from his lineage. So we all we
all we all have a little bit of that in
us. We all we have a trace of all. Look,
you even have a trace of African in you.
>> The the Hebrew Israelites are going to
get upset about. [laughter]
>> So right now right now Noah what is his
religion? You follow he followed Yahweh?
>> What is his religion though?
>> Follow Yahweh. There wasn't no name for
it.
>> What is following Yahweh mean? Following
alum
the the ever living, right?
>> A lot of people believe about all of
that.
>> Yahweh. Isn't Yahweh mean ever living in
Hebrew? It mean it means the existing
one. The self
>> the existing self-sustaining selfisting.
>> Okay. The one who believes in and
follows that. What is that action
called?
>> It doesn't have a name. You just you
just follow. You're just obedient.
>> The action of following someone. What is
that?
>> Just belief. Belief. Following.
Obedience.
>> To believe is something in your heart.
An action is something you do with your
appendages. When you actually follow a
commandment, what are you doing?
>> I don't I don't know. I thought I
answered this. I don't know where you're
getting at. Aren't you submitting or
not?
>> Uh, sure. You submit, you obey, you
believe.
>> Okay. You adhere to.
>> So, when somebody submits their will to
the creator, is that Islam or is not
Islam linguistically?
>> Uh, no.
>> No.
>> You don't know Arabic.
>> Let me tell you why.
>> You claim to know everything.
>> Well, no. Let me tell you. No,
[laughter] I don't. Let me tell you why.
Because when you like what you said
earlier, right, that to be a to be a
Muslim and to follow Islam, you cannot
just submit to anything and be a Muslim.
So to submit and be a Muslim, you have
to submit specifically to the concept of
God that is within the Quran and hadith.
>> That's not what we believe.
>> Okay. So can I I'll ask it again.
>> Wait. Allah calls Abraham. Can I But do
does
>> Allah calls the disciples of Jesus
Muslim.
>> Do do they assume that they're following
the God that's described in the Quran?
>> What do you mean they assume?
>> Like so the Quran when it's saying that
the disciples were Muslims, Abraham and
all these other kind of guys that
they're following the God that is
described in the Quran, right? So Allah
mentions about the disciples repeating
to Jesus on him.
>> He they say that we are the ones that
are going to give you victory. We are
the first amongst the Muslims at his
time.
>> Right?
>> Just like Abraham at the first of his
time. He was the first one that
permitted his will to
>> I know we understand that.
>> Just like
>> what is the Quran saying? Who's the God
that they're following?
>> They're following Allah,
>> right? So the god,
if you want to be literal about it in
Hebrew, they're following.
>> I got No. No, they're not because Okay,
>> for example, does Yahweh have children?
>> Because you're calling what do you
believe?
>> Does Yahweh have children?
>> What do you believe that word Yahweh
means?
>> It's not about the word. It's about who
the identity of Yahweh is. You hear what
I'm saying? Like any like for example,
Christians use the word Allah in in uh
in Saudi Arabia, right? Arabic
Christians, they use the word Allah.
Correct?
>> Every Arab Christian,
>> they use Allah, right?
>> The word Allah.
>> All right. Who do the Christians who do
the Arab Christians say Allah is?
depends on the Christian.
>> All right. So, who do they say it is?
>> Who do you Unitarian Christians say?
>> We're not They're not Christians. We're
not Christians.
>> According to you.
>> Okay. Are Ahmedia Muslims?
>> No. Exactly. According to you,
>> verifiable from my scripture to
>> Exactly. And I have objective evidence
from my scriptures to say Unitarians who
deny the deity of Christ are not
Christians. So, hold on. Hold on. I was
on my point. I was on my point. Okay.
Tell me your point. So,
>> when you're talking about submission and
belief, right? Huh?
>> The Christians, the Arab Christians,
they use the term Allah and they say
that Allah is Jesus. Correct.
>> No, it depends.
>> Oh, come on.
>> Okay, let's let's let's narrow it down
this way.
>> No, I I know Lebanese Christians. I know
Jordan.
>> I can I can call a Lebanese Christian
right now.
>> Christians. I know I Christian. Some of
them calan. And some of them also
Ashuri, right? There's different people,
different beliefs. Some of them believe
that God is God. Some of them believe is
Jesus's god. Some of them believe a
triune god.
>> I don't care about the heretic heritage.
>> Heritage. They would say you're a
heretics.
>> I don't care. So would how many Muslims
say that about you too? But based on
what? That's the thing.
>> Exactly. So look, this is my point.
>> What is your objective?
>> The Bible. The Bible.
>> Okay. Where does Jesus in the Bible say
to follow?
>> Hold on. Hold on. That's a That's a
different segue. I can get to a
different segway
>> because we're talking about whether or
not Listen, you just asked me a
question. You got to let me talk. You
just asked me a question. The reason why
that's that's off the topic right now is
we're not talking about whether or not
Jesus says to follow the Bible. We're
talking about whether or not Jesus is a
Muslim. And so to be a Muslim, we're
trying to define what this is means that
you look just hold on a second.
>> Right? So when some when a Lebanese when
a Lebanese Christian
>> says that Jesus is Allah,
>> are they a Muslim?
>> Of course not.
>> Why not?
>> Because they're not following the
information that came.
>> Boom. So even though they're using the
word Allah doesn't mean they're Muslim.
Because you use the word I can point to
this building and say this is my Allah.
You wouldn't say I'm a Muslim. So it
doesn't matter the word you use. It
matters who you're identifying as your
God.
>> You believe Noah is a believer?
>> I don't believe he's a believer in Allah
in your Allah.
>> Do you believe he's in heaven?
>> Yes.
>> Do you believe he was a prophet to his
people?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So that prophet got commandments
from the create. How do I know? How do I
affirm it? How do I believe in it?
because of Quran and Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasall.
>> Okay, so now here's what I'm saying.
>> The last and final messenger came to
clarify the information of the
messengers of the past.
>> Okay, that's cool. So now, how do you
know when you're saying that Muhammad is
clarifying the messengers of the past,
specifically Jesus? How do you know that
Muhammad is right when he says that
Jesus believed in the same God that he
does?
>> Because of all of the miracles that are
there that we have in the Quran and in
the hadith.
>> Let me ask you this. Let's say I go
through all the pages of the Quran,
right? And everything that's in this
Quran seems to comes out and it's
correct. It gets all these facts right.
But there's one thing it gets wrong.
Will the Quran be uh the word of God?
>> What is your definition of a fact and
what do you think?
>> If something if something is true, if
something correlates or corresponds to
reality, it's true, right? If it's
factual. Okay. So it say the Quran gets
everything right, but there's one thing
that it got wrong.
>> Would it be the word of God?
>> If it got what wrong?
>> Anything. I'm just saying anything. If
it got one thing wrong, would it be the
word of God?
>> So if there is a contradiction or error
in it, if there's an error,
>> Allah subhana wa ta'ala already
mentioned as a challenge in it that if
there's an error or contradiction, then
it wouldn't be from Allah.
>> Beautiful. So guess what? You can show
me all these miracles. You can show me
all these facts that the Quran gets
right.
>> I'm asking about okay, let's test if it
got this right because it could get it
could have got everything else right. If
it gets wrong that Jesus is a Muslim,
it's not from God.
>> That's not the criteria though.
>> What do you mean? You just gave it to
me. If it has one error, then it's over.
>> What? Let's assume you never went to
school and you never learned how to
count and you thought three equals 1.
And I'm someone that has a degree in
>> or 99 equals one,
>> whatever, right? That's not the same
thing because having an attribute,
>> you can love, you can I thought we were
just talking something. No, because it
it's not the same because you don't
believe that the three and one are
attributes. You believe they're three.
>> Wait, what are you What are you talking
about? What do you mean three in one? I
thought we were talking about math. I am
talking about money.
>> Oh, so when I said 99, you you you you
thought something interesting.
>> You grew up thinking that 3 equals 1.
And I cannot explain that as a reality
to you because you don't understand it.
Right? You won't accept it because
[music] you're set that 3 equals 1.
>> Okay?
>> If I come and tell you this book says
clearly 1 + 1 what equals 3,
>> but you keep thinking that it equals 1.
>> Mhm.
>> I'm not going to be able to get through
to you if you have something you're just
stuck on.
>> That's fine. But who has the truth? You
or me?
>> That's why you can't you have to make
sure you have to see your basic
>> in your example just with your listen
with your example that you get cuz I
like the example. Who has the truth? You
or me.
>> Yeah. You have to see the evidence. You
went and you looked and you said that
that's the thing that you believe that
God is Jesus peace be upon him. You said
that, right?
>> You're not answering the question, bro.
>> I am answering the question.
>> Stick stick with your analogy cuz your
analogy was beautiful.
>> My analogy is if you're stuck on that
what you think.
>> Yeah. If I'm if I'm stuck on a falsehood
>> and you're stuck on it and you're like,
I'm not going to accept what you're
telling me because I've grown up
thinking this is the right one.
>> Yeah. I'm saying that that's my reason
for believing this. And then you come
and you say, "Here's one stick. Here's
another stick and here's a third stick.
How many sticks are there? That's three.
1 plus 1 plus 1 is three. You give me
the evidence. Which one of us has the
truth?"
>> The one who has evidence.
>> Okay. And so therefore, that's what I'm
asking for when we're talking about the
Quran's claim, right? Mhm.
>> The claim is Jesus was a Muslim.
>> So now I'm asking for I need you to put
the sticks in front of me to show me
that this equals Jesus is a Muslim. Show
me that the Quran is right.
>> Allah subhana wa ta'ala mentions right
that every single prophet came as a
guidance to their people. Right.
>> It's a circular because it's from the
Quran. Well, you don't accept the Quran.
>> No, it's not that I don't accept the
Quran. I I actually I accept some parts
of the Quran, but the part that's not
corrupted. jumped over Noah. You jumped
over Noah because Noah
>> I don't care about Noah right now agree
on Noah as being a prophet.
>> You told him you told me that Noah
>> submitted his will to the creator.
>> So what?
>> Submitting that will to the creator.
That act of submission is Islam.
>> According to No, it's not.
>> It is an act
>> because if Noah is submitting to Yahweh
God who is a triune deity, then he's not
a submitter. He's not Islam.
>> Every single person up until what you
believe.
>> Who you can hold that thought. It's not
that's fine. My point Hold on, Mashia. I
just heard you. My point is Mashia. If
you're saying that these people I got
you and neither do Ahmed Muslims believe
what you believe. Neither does the Shia
behind you believe what you believe. So
if you're saying let me let me finish.
If you're listen if you're saying if
you're saying the reason why you believe
this is cuz the Quran says so. How do
you know the Quran got this right?
Because the Quran says so. How do you
know the Quran is right? Because
Muhammad's a prophet. How do you know
Muhammad's a prophet? cuz the Quran says
so. You have nothing of no evidence. You
just have claims that's going in a
circle. It's circular reasoning which by
definition is illogical. If you ask me
for example, no, like for example, if
you ask me how do you how do you know
Avery that Jesus is the Messiah? You
think I'm going to say because the New
Testament says so? No. I'm going to go
to you and say because Isaiah said that
the Messiah is going to come in the
flesh. I'm going to say because
Zachariah said that Yahweh is going to
come in the flesh and be pierced. I'm
going say because some I'm going say
because Psalm said because Psalm said
that he's going to have his hands and
feet. No, I didn't say in the New Test
No, you asked. No, I just said I'm not
I'm not pointing.
>> Where where in the Old Testament does it
say Jesus is the Messiah?
>> It's off of what it even came down in
interpreting it in your own way without
a basis.
>> You're not you're missing it. You're
missing it. Listen.
>> Okay. For me, for me, I can say that
someone who's an Ahmedi is not Muslim
because they're not following what is in
the Quran where Allah says obey Allah
and his messenger where Allah subhana t
says it's not upon upon any believing
man or woman to take their own opinion.
>> Okay,
>> believing man or woman.
>> Yeah.
>> If they have their own opinion, they're
not allowed to take it if Allah and the
messenger have already decreed in it.
>> We have a basis something to
>> derive our wisdom that the words of God
came from
if someone's not a Muslim, right?
opposed to what you have the scripture
of the Jews and the scripture that you
claim from you're not even following
your own thought. I am the one that you
claim to be from Jesus the New Testament
from the disciples of Jesus peace be
upon him
>> and what came down to the Jews you're
deriving the wisdom from that Bible upon
your own opinion because from your own
sect or different sects of Christianity
will have their own opinion
>> the only person that has given their own
opinion is you so far bro I've been
asking you for evidence you haven't
given me nothing but opinion circular
opinion
>> the evidence is right if Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala sent messengers. There would
have to be clear evidence without a
doubt
>> that what
>> my [clears throat] invitation to
everyone on the stream.
>> Oh my gosh.
>> And to you from before is what? To come
check and see what is that evidence.
>> Oh my gosh. Is that not what we're doing
right now?
>> Michelle. Michelle, I I I have to cut in
here.
>> What is it different? I
>> I have to I have to cut in here. These
words. I have to cut in here, brother.
>> These words that I'm telling you.
>> I have to cut in here.
>> The words I'm You said that you're going
to give me evidence or you invite us to
evidence. Wait, hold on a second. And
did what? Hold on a second. The only So
it looks like we got to talk over each
other. The only thing Isaiah So the only
thing that you have done is given me
claim after claim after claim. When I
gave you an example, when you say, for
example, you say, I know that an Amad
Muslim is is not a Muslim because based
off what the Quran says, not on your own
opinion, but the Quran tells you what a
Muslim is. So therefore, if someone does
not in accordance to what the Quran
says, they're not a Muslim. Right? Very
good. So you have some objective
standard on how to judge a Muslim. I
have an objective standard. Wait, let me
finish.
>> Let me tell you. You're not even
listening. I am.
>> So when I say something like for Jesus
to be the Messiah, right? Nowhere in the
Old Testament does it say Jesus is the
Messiah. We find that revelation in the
New Testament. So what is the New
Testament? How do I know the New
Testament is right when it says Jesus is
the Messiah? Because I go back to the
Old Testament where the Messiah
originates and I see how Jesus fulfilled
this requirement. this requirement, this
requirement, checks this off, checks
this off, checks this off. That's how I
know the New Testament got this right.
So, wait, let me lend it. So, it's not
circular. It's using objective evidence
and saying Jesus follows this. So, when
I ask you, look, the Quran tells me what
a Muslim is. Beautiful. I'm with you on
that. Show me that Jesus fulfills the
requirement objectively, not because the
Quran says so. Show me where Jesus
showed that he's a Muslim. where Allah
subhana t says when he spoke to the
children of Israel, I am the servant of
God.
>> Circular reasoning.
>> Now, now the same circular reasoning
where you took that same Bible to
explain the Bible, where in the Bible
does Jesus tell you to go follow that
Bible?
>> Oh my gosh,
>> Michelle.
Because
>> if you was on my stage, I would have
kicked you by now, bro.
>> Look,
>> where does it say? Because I have no
reason to follow the way I follow based
upon my religion.
>> What is what is the reason that you have
to believe that Jesus is Muslim?
>> Why are you following?
>> That's a that's a separate question.
That's a separate question.
>> You brought it up. You just you just
explained what your belief about Jesus
peace be upon him
>> specifically about being Messiah and why
I where I get that from.
>> And you tried to put up the the New
Testament on a pedestal.
>> No, the the New Testament makes a claim.
I told you why I believe the New
Testament got that claim correct.
>> Because of the Old Testament.
>> Because of the evidence in the Old
Testament. Two separate divisions of the
book.
>> So,
>> so how do you know Jesus is a Muslim?
>> Because the one that sent down his
revelation and had that prophet of his
time to explain it are in two separate
revelations. The hadith and the Quran.
All of them vetted to the time with the
full integrity of every single link in
that chain. So we know so I don't have
to come 1400 in your case 2,000 years
later and say who is Luke? Why do I
believe Luke? Why do I I believe Paul?
Why do I is this correct?
>> Yeah. You're going to Abu Herrera and
going to Ibafir and going and going to
Abkari and going to all these guys like
like come on you know his name's name
look don't don't don't hop on that bro
it's not like father hadith that he
memorized time of his time of
>> I don't care what he he memorized
>> birth his death all of that is memorized
>> like for example with Muslims look in
the Quran you don't know anything about
Jesus and how he practices religion
>> I that's not the question
>> it is the question
>> no the question is about Jesus. How did
he pray?
>> The question is exactly how did Jesus
pray? How would you take what you know
about Jesus from someone who's unknown?
>> Okay, so let's talk about Muhammad who's
known. How did Jesus pray?
>> He prayed the way he prayed.
>> What we have left of the remnants,
>> right, is that he he bowed his face
down.
>> Where do you get that from?
>> That is from the remnants.
>> What? What remnant? Where
>> the remnants that are there in the Old
Testament and New Testament? The New
>> So in order for you to know that how
Jesus prayed, you got to come to the
Bible.
>> No. Okay, then don't use the Bible
there.
>> I know I know that all of the prophets
came with the same guidance from Allah.
>> So, how do you know Jesus bowed his head
to the ground and prayed? How do you
know that?
>> Okay, you want to Have you ever been to
a synagogue?
>> Forget the synagogue.
>> Have you ever been to a synagogue?
>> Yes. I don't care about that. To the
lost sheep.
>> How did Jesus pray?
>> Was he sent to the lost sheep of
>> I don't care about that. How did he
pray?
>> You just take their scriptures to make
your scriptures
>> whatever you want to say. How did Jesus
pray? How do they pray in the synagogue?
>> Wait, you're saying that Jesus pray like
the Jews?
>> I'm telling you, how do they pray?
Right.
>> You're just ask You're just asking
another question. You're not answering
it.
>> I'm telling you, how do you see?
>> Do like the Jews, do they pray like
Muslims pray similarly?
>> No.
>> Do Eastern Orthodox Christians pray?
>> How do you know that? How do you know
Jesus prayed similar to you?
>> Do they pray like us or not?
>> Who?
>> The Eastern Orthodox Christians.
>> I don't care about the Eastern Orthodox
Christians. You guys copy them. My
question Yes.
>> How do you know how Jesus prayed? Stay
focused. How do you know Jesus prayed?
>> Focus the [laughter]
how he prayed exactly verbatim. Allah
says
every single person from those people
that were sent, right? They had certain
legislations and a certain method,
>> right?
>> What was Jesus's method of praying?
>> That method verbatim of praying, right?
>> That salah begin.
>> Oh my. Yes. Yes.
It matches our salah as Muslim.
>> How do you know exactly verbatim if
there was an extra less? It's not known
to me 100%.
>> So you don't know.
>> But you don't not matter because
erases what came with the previous.
>> I got you. No worries. Did Jesus fast
him?
>> Did he erased what came with the
previous?
>> I got you. So you don't know how Jesus
prayed. Did he fast?
>> The prophets of Allah fasted.
>> How do you know Jesus fasted? Because we
have that in the Quran.
>> Show me in the Quran where it says Jesus
fasted.
>> So about the prophets of Allah.
>> No Jesus.
>> So we have that the mother of Jesus
peace be upon him
>> fasted.
>> I don't care. I care about Jesus
>> because that's
>> she fasted from speech. No, it doesn't
say
>> Zakaria. Zakaria, right? He fasted from
speech.
>> Yeah. What about what about Jesus? Did
he fast? So regardless of him like I
mentioned every single prophet they
received their own method and they
received their own way of prophet like
giving prayer and worship. I got you.
Did he did he fast?
>> Does it matter?
>> Did he fast? Did he fast?
>> I know David fasted.
>> Beautiful. Did Jesus fast? Thank you.
Thank you.
>> Most likely he fasted.
>> Wait. How do you know that? How do you
know?
>> Because we follow what is there in the
evidence. If it says that he fasted and
I'm not aware and where where what what
evidence
>> in the hadith.
>> Oh, it doesn't say that. Sorry.
>> I'm saying if it is there because I'm
not sure. I'm not recalling.
>> I know. I'm helping you out. It doesn't
it doesn't say anything about him
fasting. So, so how do you know he
fasted?
>> But it he doesn't have to follow like I
mentioned. Allah said
>> I'm not saying I'm not I'm not saying
that people of the past.
>> I'm just proving a point
>> receive their own method of worship,
their own.
>> That's fine. That's has nothing to do
what I'm saying.
>> Are separate than what we have today.
Beautiful. How do you know what was
Jesus's law in fasting?
>> Thank you. You don't know. It doesn't
matter. I'm going to tell you why it
matters. You don't know how Jesus
prayed. You don't even know if he fasted
or not. You don't even know if he taught
to fast. Here's another question. You
ready?
>> It doesn't matter.
>> Let me show you. Come down. I got you. I
got you. Where was Jesus born?
>> He was born in the Philistines.
>> Show me in the Quran where it says he
was born in Palestine.
>> He was born in that land. Was he not?
>> Where does he where do you get that?
Don't Don't ask me. Don't come to me for
help. So even your Quran tells you to
come to me. But
>> so he they were there in that land.
>> Who was?
>> Where do you how do you know Miriam was
in that land?
>> They were in that land.
>> How do you know?
>> Show me in the Quran where it says she
was in Palestine.
>> It's in the hadith.
>> No, it's not.
>> It is in the
>> Give me the hadith.
>> Where was Zachariah? Where were the
children of Israel?
>> I don't care about where Zachariah was.
I care about where Jesus was.
>> In the Quran, it mentions Zakaria
meeting.
>> It sure does. Where was Jesus, though?
where Jesus was,
>> where Abraham was, where Noah was.
>> Just say you don't know.
>> It does not matter.
>> Saying it doesn't matter is not is not
relevant.
>> It's very irrelevant. It's very relevant
because the point of the matter is Allah
said, "Do you know a binding a binder in
there about the
>> I just want to know if you know or not.
It doesn't matter if they had extra if
they had an extra thing that they said,
right? Because as Muslims, we're giving
given as a gift. It's an extra praise to
Allah, right? What they had is different
than what we had, but at the same time,
it's from that creator.
>> No worries. So, you don't know if Jesus
fasted. You don't know if he You don't
know. You don't know where he prayed.
Excuse me. You're a Shia. You don't
follow Sunni. You're a Shia.
>> You don't You don't know if You don't
know how Jesus fasted. You don't know.
You don't know. You don't know how he
prayed. Excuse me. Oh, you got to save
him.
>> You don't know where Jesus was.
>> Let me ask you this. Here's one more
thing.
>> Where where was where who were his
disciples? There's a hadith about him
fasting.
>> Where where was his where was his
disciples?
>> But he he fasted and he did.
>> How do you know he fasted? How do you
know he fasted?
>> No, it's not.
>> Yes. Ahmed.
>> Where is this from? Ahmed.
>> Read it. Read it.
>> And And then give us the authenticity of
it.
>> What is this?
Ahmed.
>> No. Wait. Hold on. What? What is What is
this chat GBT?
>> Chad GBT. Bring me the source.
>> Ahmed.
>> So go to Muslim and bring me the source.
Okay, you can check it.
>> Yeah, that's crazy. Chad DBT.
>> So, like I mentioned, like I mentioned,
having what we know about Jesus, what we
need to know about him today, we need to
know about him.
>> Do so, do you know, do you know any of
these information that I ask you these
answers to the question?
>> What? Why is it relevant? Why not?
>> I'm going to show you. I'm going to show
you why. Because you don't know
anything. Let me tell you why it's
relevant.
>> Prophet received their
>> It's relevant because you don't know
anything about Jesus from your sources.
I'm showing you that. You don't know.
You don't know how, let me finish. You
don't know how he practiced his
religion. You don't know how he prayed.
You don't know if he fasted or how he
fasted. You don't even know how long he
fasted or if he taught the fast. No,
hold on. Let me let me fasting.
>> You don't even know where he was from.
>> Verify that because it's from yours.
>> You don't know where he was from.
>> How do you not know where he's from?
>> No. How do you know? How do you not know
where he was from?
>> So, one second.
Right.
>> Crazy.
According to what we believe, right? I
no you tell me from your sources where
was she
was I don't care about no tops we have
what does it say
>> where does your Quran or hadith say that
>> serious says that
>> I don't care about no commentary you're
stealing from the Bible
>> all of the all of the they're based upon
aith some of the stuff some of the are
based on Israelite sources right like
they have some he mentions it and he
says it as an extra information. But
that is beside the point. The point of
the matter is
>> who are his disciples?
>> Submitting your will to the creator.
>> No. Who are his disciples now?
>> Submitting your will. We don't know
them.
>> Boom. Okay. You don't know. Okay.
>> We don't know their name.
>> We agree that he had disciples. How many
did he have?
>> Up until the time of Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. How many did he have?
There were followers of Jesus destined
to heaven that followed that pure mon.
No worries. How many?
>> Not three in one. One.
>> How many How many disciples did he have?
How many disciples did he have?
>> We don't know need to know. It doesn't
matter. Okay. So, so here we are.
Listen, this is why I'm going to show
you why this is important. Okay?
>> You don't know where he was born.
>> You don't know where he was from.
>> You don't know if he fasted or not. You
don't know if he taught to fast. You
don't know how he prayed. You don't know
who his disciples were. You don't even
know how many disciples he had.
>> From from your No, you don't. From your
Quran and Hadith, this is the point.
From your sources, you don't know
anything about Jesus. But everything
that you say we know what we need to
know to be authenticated.
>> There's one time that you gave me an
answer on how Jesus prayed. You said he
prayed like us and he prostrated from
the remnants that we find. And I asked
you where are these remnants? You said
it's from your Bible from the Old
Testament and New Testament. So the only
place that you could get information
about Jesus is from the Bible.
>> So you need the Bible for for
information on Jesus. So the Bible will
tell us if he's a Muslim or not.
>> Let me tell you how it is. Tell me
>> now our prophet peace bless be upon him
said from your scriptures where you at
anything as a lie and not to accept it
as absolute truth. So wait wait wait
wait say it again. Say it again.
>> When he said we heard it.
>> No I I need a hearing. I'm talking to
you.
>> So we don't accept everything as
absolute truth. Nor do we accept
everything as a lie unless it's a clear
lie against what
>> from what?
>> From the old scriptures.
>> No that's a lie. So no
>> the hadith. No. No. Muhammad. No. Let me
stop you right here. Muhammad said, "Do
not believe." When you listen to the
people of the book,
he says, "Don't believe what they say,
nor disbelieve what they say." But he,
and watch this. This is going to be the
killer. He says, "But say we believe in
what was given to us and what was given
to you." So Muhammad said, "Believe in
their books."
>> Yes. No, he didn't say that. What was
given to
>> Babe, give me your phone, please.
>> We believe in it.
>> We going to bring this up to What's the
only thing we do, y'all?
>> We believe in it. We just read.
>> How do we know Allah says in the Quran
that the the Quran itself is something
that you should tripping the I'm going
to show you the hadith. Watch the No,
you don't because you you just said that
Muhammad said don't believe in the
books.
>> The came to Isa. I believe that's not
what that's came to Moses. That's not
what he says. All right. We going to
see. But I don't believe the Bible are
those things. That's cool.
>> That is why I say something that is good
where a prophet is prostrating to his
Lord in Islam. This is something that
maybe yes Isaam did without affirming it
because it's not in my sources
>> the religion of maybe
>> this is what we have as truth but does
it matter no because
right the messiah when he comes down and
he kills the antichrist he's going to be
a follower of Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam praying in following what
Muhammad came with
and he's going to rule the earth as a
king but as a king that is a human
worship worshiping Allah alone.
>> All right. You ready?
>> I know the hadith.
>> You do?
>> Yeah.
>> So, does the hadith I'm going to give
you a chance. Does the hadith say to
reject their books or does it say to
reject what they say?
>> In Arabic?
>> Yeah, I have it in Arabic.
>> Uh, let me read it in Arabic. I'll read
it for you.
>> I'll read it in English first.
>> I'll read it for you and I will
translate it in Arabic.
>> No, it's right here.
>> No, no. I think they like it. I I'll
>> read Can you read it? Can you read
English first?
>> No, I'm going to read the Arabic.
>> Wait, we got English speakers here. I'll
read the Arabic first. This guy speaks
Arabic. He can verify if I'm lying. So,
let me read the Arabic.
>> Read the English first.
>> I'll read the Arabic and I will
translate verbatim what it says.
>> I'll read in English and then I'll give
it to you.
>> Uh, then you want to you want to take a
translation?
>> I'm I'm going to hand you the phone.
>> No, no, no. Let me read in Arabic.
>> Hold on. This
No, no, no. Arabic for you. 7362. I'm
going to give it to you. I do. I'm going
to give it to you in Arabic. If you
don't read, I'll give it to him. Okay.
Saiukari 7362.
>> Narrated Abu Herrera. There he is again.
M
>> the people of the book used to read the
Torah in Hebrew.
>> Remember that brother said that they
didn't have the Torah earlier today.
>> Oh, but they had the Torah reading in
Hebrew in Mam, right? Hey, that's crazy.
The people of the book,
>> the Jews.
>> To the Jews used to read the Torah in
Hebrew and then explain it in Arabic to
the Muslims.
>> They still have the Torah today. You
know, you go any synagogue, they have
something that's called the Torah.
>> Oh, that's beautiful.
>> Okay, cool. Um Allah's apostle said
do not believe the people of the book.
Does he say don't believe the book or
the people?
>> People
>> people. Right. Okay. Don't believe the
people of the book nor disbelieve them
but say we believe in Allah and whatever
is revealed to us which is what?
>> Quran.
>> Okay. And whatever is revealed to you
which is what?
>> What was sent down to Isa and Moses.
>> Torah and Gospel. Right.
>> Yeah. So they supposed to believe in the
Quran and the Torah and Gospel, but what
they say they take it with a grain of
salt, right?
>> It specifically says do not believe
them.
>> Exactly. But
>> extrapolates onto you.
>> And then explicitly says believe the
books though, right?
>> No, it says to believe what was set down
to them.
>> So we believe we believe in Allah and
whatever is revealed to us.
>> Uhhuh.
>> And whatever is revealed to you.
>> Yeah. Books. Okay.
>> The books. Right.
>> Okay. Right.
>> What was revealed to them?
>> You you already said the Torah in jail,
right?
>> Yes.
>> Right. Correct. No. No. Correct. Was it
changed? No. Can you answer the
question?
>> Yes. They believe what was sent down to
Jesus was sent down to Jesus peace be
upon him. Read the
>> What was sent down to Alam was sent down
to M. Read.
So the people of the book used to recite
the Torah in Hebrew
and they would give the ex Jesus of it
to the people of Islam in Arabic.
So the prophet of Allah may the peace
and blessings of Allah be upon him and
his salutations
do not believe the people of the book.
Do not call them liars. meaning do not
take from them.
>> Do not disbelieve them or or believe
them.
>> Verily we believe in Allah and we
believe on that which is sent down to us
and that which was sent down to you.
>> Ah so according to the hadith like I
said you said earlier and you know if we
all make mistakes it's okay. You said
earlier that the hadith that Muhammad
said don't believe in their books. It
says don't believe in what they have,
right? Because there could be truth and
falsehood in it.
>> That's the understanding.
>> But no, but that's not
>> because we believe was there.
>> But that's not what he says. Muhammad
said, let me finish.
>> Who wrote those books?
>> No, I'm I'm going to give it to you. I
promise. I'm going to listen to you. Let
me let me let me say this.
>> You believe
>> Muhammad said Muhammad says
specifically, he said to don't believe
in what they say or reject what they say
because what they say could be true.
What they say could be a lie. But he
says but believe in Allah. say we
believe in Allah and what is what was
revealed to us which is the Quran and
what Allah sent down to them which is
the Torah gospel. So according to the
Quran
>> according to um not the Quran according
to Muhammad they have to believe in the
books they can't reject the books and
say oh some is good some is not. No they
have to believe in whatever was sent
down to the Torah gospel.
>> The books that were sent down by God or
sent to the people by Paul.
>> It said it says sent by by Paul. Yeah.
>> What does it say?
>> Where does it say anything about Paul?
>> What was sent down by Allah to them or
what was sent to the people by Paul?
What does it say?
>> Okay, I I'll go with you.
>> Because is Paul followers?
>> Poor Paul.
>> Is he considered to you?
>> Yes, of course.
>> Okay. So, didn't my prophet say not to
believe?
>> No. He said don't believe them or
disbelieve them. So, you can't even say
Paul's a liar.
>> I Why you say Paul's a liar? take the
full information which is there in the
Quran where Allah says to use the Quran
as
>> is is Paul a liar
>> a judge a criterion to know what is
truth and what is false
>> where does the Quran say that
>> Allah subhana t mentions it jumping from
this now
>> okay right now stay focused cuz your
Quran don't say that your Quran don't
say that
>> Allah said right and he sent down this
is yours by the way
>> oh thank you my reminder
>> yeah so right now Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala said that he sent down a book to
the Muslims correct
>> that's correct
>> and this is what we believe The prophet
said to say you said believe what is
sent down to you and believe say to them
that we believe that was something which
we're saying we believe that Jesus got
>> wait what
>> yeah something
>> what got to you what was sent down to
you right
>> the
>> okay so you have to believe in them
>> yes that they were sent down not believe
in them
>> oh okay I got you so when it says but we
so say we believe in Allah and whatever
so in Allah and in whatever was sent
Right. Yes. Yes. This is an article of
faith. I can't be a Muslim if I say
there was never a Torah.
>> You're jumping the gun. You're jumping
the gun. Okay. Watch this.
>> I believe it, but I don't believe in it
today. You're jumping the gun. Watch.
>> So, believe in Allah and whatever was
revealed to us and whatever was revealed
to you.
>> So, you have to believe in what they
have, not just that they have it or just
that it was revealed.
>> I believe there's a Torah.
>> No. Do Do you believe Do you believe in
it?
>> I believe there was. Do you believe in
it? Do you believe in the Torah?
>> I believe it that was sent down.
>> Do you believe in the Torah?
>> The only way for me to believe that they
are Muslim.
>> Do you believe in the Torah
>> is that they receive scriptures from
Allah?
>> Do you believe in the Torah? Do you
believe in the Torah?
>> Do you know what means [laughter]
book?
>> The the the law. I'm not going to get
past this.
>> The Tawra of Moses. I believe in it.
What is there?
>> Do they have it?
>> The book that they call Did they Did
they have it in affirm? Did they did
they have it in Moses? Did they have it?
When Muhammad said this hadith, did they
have the Torah?
>> According to what is here,
>> the prophet said, "Do not believe them."
That's not what I asked you.
>> Do not lie to them.
>> Do they have the Torah?
>> Can I say
>> the full Torah?
>> Can I ask
>> The full Torah that was sent down to
Moses.
>> The people, let me read.
>> Why was Why was Jesus sent to the
children of Israel?
>> Notice another question.
>> No, no, no, no, no. The the people of
the book the people of the book used to
read the Torah in Hebrew and then
explain it in Arabic. Do they have the
Torah?
>> The full Torah that was sent out to
Moses. No.
>> So, uh, hey, I'm Hey, Muhammad. I'm so
sorry. Misha, he hates you because he
says that you're saying the opposite.
You said they have the Torah, Muhammad.
He's saying they don't have it. I'm
sorry, Muhammad. Man, my my bad,
Muhammad.
>> Go, go, go. Let's see. What does it say?
Does it say Muhammad or does it say at
the top?
>> Allah's Apostle.
>> Okay. Allah's apostle. Huh?
>> Who's Allah's Apostle?
What present?
Who said? Who said?
So the confir from who?
>> From who?
>> He's saying this hadith
>> from who?
>> He's saying this
>> from who? Who is he reciting it from?
Who's he reporting from?
>> So okay, let's go back in English.
>> What is written?
Abuur. You got
>> Abu Hur narrated and Abu Hurra said
>> wait narrated from who? He's saying
this. He's saying this.
>> Narrated verse from who?
>> The hadith is people who are reporting
what who said right who said it.
>> This hadith what he's saying are the
words of Abuur and who the beginning of
this hadith is from Abuur. He says I'll
give you from the direct everything
to who? Who? Who does it all go all the
way back to
said?
>> So Abu said what
>> said
the people of the book
they the people of the book were
reciting the reciting and they were and
explaining it in Arabic and then what
happened?
This is whereas Allah starts talking.
>> So who is who is Abu Haring?
>> Now after the fact of him mentioning
that they had the Torah.
>> Allah.
>> So good.
>> What did So
>> he said do not believe them. Meaning
this is not the Torah. Do not
>> do not BELIEVE
[laughter]
meaning there is not full truthhthood in
it.
>> So what was they recite? What were they
reading? for the last hour.
>> What was I reading? What was I reading?
>> Okay, we'll go slowly.
>> Abi, so
what did Abu say? Abra said that the
people of the book
>> they were reciting what they claimed to
be.
>> Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, WHOA, [screaming] WHOA.
>> NO, NO, NO.
>> NO, NO, NO. I'M TRYING.
>> They used to recite obviously. No, no,
just like Michelle. Michelle, don't tell
me what your explanation is. Read the
text. Does Abu Hura say what they claim
is the Torah or does Abu Hera say it's
the Torah?
>> Let him speak. One second.
>> Yeah. What does it say verbatim? Go
ahead.
>> So Abu Herra says that the people of the
book reciting the Torah in Hebrew.
>> So does Abu Herra say they had the
Torah?
>> So he said what they were doing
obviously. So
>> like you in your time today
>> which you do not have the exact Arabic
whatever they had at the time of the
Arabs difference.
>> This is Hebrew.
>> So they had their ex Jesus in Hebrew. In
Arabic you don't have
>> I don't care about their ex Jesus. I
care about the book.
>> So that book what they had what they
were saying.
>> Was it the Torah?
>> One second. One second. [laughter]
According to them
>> because it's according to them.
>> According to who?
>> Abu Hurra.
>> Thank you. So wait is Abu Hurra wrong?
IS HE WRONG?
>> YES. [screaming]
WHY? [laughter]
>> WHY? Because Allah corrects him.
>> Where does he correct him?
>> Where he says, "No, wait, wait, wait."
>> Where he says, "No, no, no, no,
brother."
>> Because he mentions him. I missed it.
>> He mentions [laughter]
he mentions
do not believe them. Meaning they were
giving a Does that mean the is correct?
>> Okay.
>> Does that mean the Torah is correct? No.
>> Wait, wait, wait.
Watch this y'all.
Watch this. Do not believe the people of
the book.
>> Can I get my girl's phone? [laughter]
You're
>> like, "No, no.
Do not make call them liars, right?"
Why? The people of the book.
>> So, not the book itself.
>> Do Yes. The people.
>> The people. Not the book.
>> Yes. Just say we believe in Allah and
what is sent to us and what was sent to
you.
>> So, they have to believe in their books.
>> We believe this is part of our faith.
One of the things that was sent from
God.
>> Are you a Muslim? Yes, I am.
>> You can come in.
>> Okay, can I come in?
>> Yeah, go ahead.
>> In short, I know you guys want the
clickbait. You want the
>> No, no, don't don't don't want the
truth.
>> Here's what here's what we believe in as
Muslim.
>> We don't care about what you believe. We
want
>> It's okay. No, no, let him let him go.
>> Here's what we believe in. That hadith,
>> what the prophet was saying, Abu Har
came to the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. He was saying, "We heard if I
can read it one more time."
>> Yeah, go ahead. He said
>> the people and the of the book used to
read the Torah in Hebrew. This is Abu
Hera saying this to the prophets right
>> and then explain it in Arabic to the
Muslims.
Allah's apostle which is the prophet
prophet Muhammad now as narrated that's
when the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam says correcting like the said
correcting Abu do not believe the people
of the book nor disbelieve them because
as Muslims we believe that Allah sent
down the Torah Allah sent down the Bible
which is the um
>> the gospel but we believe that God
altered and corrupted the modern
>> you know that's a lieution
of books that's why he looked at
Can I finish? Can I finish? Let him
land. Can I finish the Torah and the
gospel? We believe in those. The Torah
was sent to Moses. We believe that the
gospel was sent down to to Jesus. We
believe that David Alisam also received
some some scriptures. We the Zabur we
believe that those were sent down. Yes.
But then we believe that those got
corrupted. So we don't believe in the
modern scriptures of the Bible which is
the Torah and the Gospel. We believe
that of the We believe in the original
ones. That's why that's why Allah sent
down the Quran after so he can correct
the belief.
>> Okay, let's stop here. Let's stop here.
Okay, so everybody understood this
point. So bas basically the previous
scriptures are corrupted. This is the
reason why Allah sent the Quran because
it was all messed up. The Quran comes
pure unadulterated to fix what was
messed up before. Okay. So and you
believe that the Quran is a judge over
these scriptures. It decides what's
right and wrong, what's true and false.
Right.
>> Well, don't say that they are untruth.
We don't know what's exactly what's
exactly
>> I got you. So let's break this down.
Okay. So it says the people of the book
used to read the Torah,
>> right?
>> And then explain it in Arabic. Right.
>> Right.
>> And then it says Allah's apostles said
to the Muslims,
>> "Do not believe the people of the book."
>> Right.
>> So can we agree that there's a
distinction between the people of the
book and the books themselves?
>> Sure. Definitely is different than a
person. Yes.
>> Right. So the people can be saying
something and it could be a lie cuz the
book doesn't say that. Right. Could be
false.
>> Could be could be true, could be false.
So Muhammad says don't believe the
people of the book what they're saying
because what they could say is the lie
could be the truth right but he says um
nor disbelieve what they say
>> sure
>> however say this we believe in Allah and
what was revealed to us and what was
revealed to you right
>> so they have they believe in the books
that they have they just can't take what
they say cuz they don't know if it's
true or not based on the book right
>> one more time say one more time
>> so they can't so Muhammad tells them you
can't trust what they say Okay.
>> Right. However, you have to trust the
books they have. Correct.
>> Not the not the current books.
>> It so it says believe in what was
revealed to us and what is revealed to
you.
>> Not what you have, not in your
possession.
>> Hold on a second. It says, okay, so hold
on a second.
Wait. It's okay. Big Mike, it's all
goody. So when he says we believe in in
Allah and what is revealed to us, right?
>> Does that mean that they have the Quran?
>> What was revealed to the prophets?
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. Yes.
>> It says us what was revealed to us,
>> which is the Quran. Yes.
>> So, do they have the Quran?
>> Yes.
>> What do you mean have?
>> Do they have it in their possession,
brother?
>> No. At the time, I don't think at the
time it was printed yet.
>> In this memorization,
>> in in this time, do they have possession
of the Quran
>> in their hearts and as memorization?
Yes. I don't believe at the time they
had print.
>> Okay. So, wait on a second.
>> What do you mean by possession?
>> So, meaning that they have the Quran.
They have access to the Quran.
>> Yeah. Because the the the prophet
whenever it was revealed to him by angel
Gabriel
>> he recited to the people so they have
access to it. Yes.
>> Okay. So then it says and whatever is
revealed to you do they have possession
of the scriptures.
>> Well did they get did they get that
revealed to them?
>> Does it it says it?
>> But the people those people
>> it says it it says whatever is revealed
to you.
>> No say the
[clears throat]
which means
>> what was sent down to you.
>> Okay. So, so that's even better. I like
that. The Torah Gospel. So, do so, so
they have the Torah Gospel, right? Just
really really quick. Let me let me end
this. Let me land this. Let me finish.
Let me
>> So, they have the Torah and Gospel,
right?
>> They have a a version of the Quran. I
mean, of the Torah or the Gospel
>> and they have to believe in it, right?
>> We have to believe in the original Torah
and the original Gospel
>> according to this. Do they have the
Torah?
>> They No, we It says what was revealed to
you,
>> brother. See, this is this is the
problem that I'm having. Okay. The
problem, let me let me
>> Okay, you can finish and I'll have a
>> Yeah. The problem that I have is that
we're looking at a at the at the line,
>> okay?
>> And we're reading it verbatim and it
says they were reading the Torah,
>> but when I talked to the Muslims, you
guys say they didn't have the Torah
>> just like
So, who should I believe the father?
>> Should I believe him? Should I believe
Muhammad or should I believe you guys?
We believe the prophet. We We're
explaining what the prophet Muhammad is
saying. Look up what the word reveal
means. What does it mean?
>> What does it mean for Allah to send down
something? Does it mean that you have
the possession of it the same thing that
was sent down to God?
>> You have to go and study because after
the fact after 1,400 years of Muslims
showing Christians
not only changed meanings from the
Greek, but they even removed one of the
definitions of it.
>> Thank you. Yeah, that's it.
>> Oh, wait. No, this not the camera bag.
It's all right though.
>> Now you should have had
>> but we're back on so this works.
>> But about the blue chargers about his
god is saying
>> Oh yeah, you're right. The mic is back
on. Nice. Oh, we're good.
>> I haven't
to you while I'm saying with you
is the Holy Spirit.
>> The Holy Spirit. Jesus saying your
console in the Holy Spirit in verse 25.
Oh, that's corrupted. But the one you
ask me
>> the count of the Holy Spirit.
>> Yeah.
>> So the Holy Spirit is going to be sent.
>> Okay. We believe that the Holy Spirit is
the one that gave the revelation to you
know what the Holy Spirit is.
>> You don't
ask about [laughter] the Holy Spirit.
>> I have the right
no that's about the spirit of humanity
in general. Not the Holy Spirit.
>> No
spirit.
Yeah.
The Septu and the Dead Sea Scrolls
validate the old the Old Testament.
>> Can I give you one verse?
>> Exactly. Give me one verse.
>> So, I got in my truck.
[laughter]
>> Can Can we pause here real quick? I'm
back online. I wanted to show you
something.
>> All right. He's g
>> Wanted to show you back.
>> You want to keep it warm for you?
[clears throat and laughter]
>> Yeah. Yeah. Just kept it warm. Keep it
going.
Where's the uh where's the other
brother? Is the other brother still
here? Who was uh danger? This was this
was for both of you guys. Okay. Yeah.
So, so remember so remember we were we
were discussing on whether or not the
Jews and the Christians had the Torah
gospel. Muhammad said they did. Abu
Herrera said they did. But
>> No, no, no, no.
>> But the Muslims say they did. Muslim
said they did.
>> Mama never said it.
>> That they had it.
>> Yeah, they didn't have
>> his time. Yeah.
>> He said do not trust them.
>> He says believe in what was real to you
and to us.
>> Do not trust them.
>> Okay, so watch this guys. He said, "Do
not call them lies."
>> Okay.
>> Accept everything as truth. But say we
got you. But so if Muhammad said it,
>> what was
>> if Muhammad said it'll be good for you,
right?
>> You guys need to take time. You guys are
>> If if Muhammad said it, it'll be good
for you. Right.
>> If Muhammad said that they had the Torah
and Gospel with them, then then they
then they had it with them. Right.
>> Right.
>> I don't understand what you're trying to
get.
>> If Muhammad said that they had the Torah
and Gospel with them, then that means
they had it with them. Right. You want
me to read the hadith?
>> I'll get it to you in a second. I just
needed to make sure you believe
Muhammad.
>> Of course. Okay. As long as it's not a a
weak hadith. What did he say exactly?
>> I asked if uh he if Muhammad said that
they have the Torah and Gospel if he'll
trust what Muhammad said.
>> What does Hadith say?
>> We're about to What is this? [snorts]
>> Great with Okay. So, it says this
>> narrated Juber bin Nufar. Did I say that
right?
>> Okay. He said no.
>> Read [laughter] it in Arabic. All right,
I'm gonna give it to you in Arabic in a
second, man.
>> It says, "From Abu Adara, who said, "We
were with the prophet when he raised his
sight to the sky. Then he said, "This is
the time when knowledge is to be taken
from the people until what remains of it
shall not amount to anything."
So Zad bin Labid al- Ansari said, "How
will it be taken from us while we recite
the Quran, right? Makes sense. If you
have the Quran, you have the knowledge,
don't you?" Right?
>> So he just refuted Muhammad. But watch
what Muhammad says.
>> He said true though.
>> Okay. Exactly. Isn't that true? Right.
This is what Muhammad says. He said,
watch.
>> He didn't refute the pro. How can he
refute the prophet?
>> That's what I'm saying. So if you have
I'm about to tell you have respect
because you're talking about a companion
>> and the prophet of Allah
>> right. So this is where respect when you
come I don't talk bad about your mom. I
don't what did I say that was bad. Let's
not do this manuted Muhammad. How is
that disrespectful? How does he how did
he recruit Muhammad?
>> Okay. I'm about to show you. Okay.
>> Okay. So if if Muhammad
>> Just keep it keep it cordial.
>> This is cordial. If I said he refuted
I'm not that's not disrespectful. I'm
just saying that he proved him wrong.
That's all. All right.
>> Yeah. We we also got to get a one for
one too. you know, you know, you got to
get get us to respond as well.
>> Of course, you want to talk about the
Trinity next.
>> Okay.
>> All right. For sure. [laughter]
Shower
and a half.
>> You're right. You're right. So, look, an
hour have doing what?
>> So, look, Muhammad says, Muhammad says,
Yeah, we've been doing this for a
minute.
>> Come on now.
>> Muhammad says that knowledge is going to
be taken from the people,
>> right?
>> Uh, Zad responds and says,
>> "Well, how can that be? because we
recite the Quran.
>> So as long as we recite the Quran,
knowledge will will be with us, right?
>> Of course.
>> So if knowledge will be with us, if
we're reciting the Quran, then therefore
Muhammad's wrong if he says that
knowledge will be taken from them.
>> That's that's not continue reading.
>> Ah, okay. So that's why I said he
refuted Muhammad. But
>> no, because when you read it in Islam,
you follow it. You It's
>> recitation, remembering, and following
through.
>> Yeah. If they have the knowledge, right?
If they're reciting on the commandments,
huh, you're going to keep them. But if
you don't follow through in Islam, we
believe the Quran is going to be lifted
up.
>> That's fine. But as long as they're
reciting it, they have knowledge of it,
right?
>> Time we're going to open these books.
There's going to be nothing left.
>> He's not talking about the end of time.
He says, "And this is the time."
>> How much longer we going to be on this
question?
>> Just a little bit.
>> He's answering, man. So, so he says, so
he says, "This is read Arabic."
>> I got you. I'm gonna give it to you.
>> He says, "This is the time where
knowledge will be taken from from the
people." Mhm.
>> The Muslim respond, the companion
responds, "How will knowledge be taken
from us when we recite the Quran?"
>> So, as long as they're reciting the
Quran, they're going to have the
knowledge.
>> But so, if that's the case, then
Muhammad's wrong that knowledge will be
taken from them. Okay? Now, that's
another subject. That's just a little
fun topic I might do on YouTube. Okay?
>> Extrapolating.
>> All right. So, watch this. So, Muhammad
responds and he says, he said, "May you
be bererieved of your mother. May your
mother die." Right? May you lose your
mother.
May your mom disown you.
>> I used to consider you among the fukaha
of the people of Alam Medina. What's
fuka mean?
>> The ones that have knowledge.
>> Okay. Thank you. He says, watch this. He
says the Torah and the angel are with
the Jews and Christians.
But what do they avail them? Right.
Juber said, "So I met Ubada bin Asam and
said to him, have you not heard what
your brother Abu Dha said? Then I
informed him of what Abu Dha said." He
said, "Abu Dada spoke the truth. If you
wish, we shall narrate to you about the
first knowledge to be removed from the
people. It is Kushu. Soon Kushu right
there, that's what it says. I don't
>> Okay. Soon you will enter the
congregational masjid but not see any
man in it with Okay. So the point of
this was no I don't but it's irrelevant
to my point.
>> It is very relevant.
>> It's not because according to this the
according to this Muhammad says yes
>> that the gospel
>> and the Torah
>> yes
>> are not was not in the past they are
with the Jews and Christians. Right.
>> You're missing the point of the whole
hadith though.
>> No I know the point of the hadith but
the point that I brought this to you is
because you are saying Muhammad never
said the Torah and Gospel is with the
Jews and Christians.
>> Can I read the Arabic? Yes. Okay.
So,
no, I don't care about him.
So, here the chain mentions that he was
withasam.
May the peace and blessings of Allah be
upon his messenger.
And he looked up into the heavens and he
said,
"This is the time where the knowledge is
starting to get lifted up from the
people
that there will be nothing left of them
to to get that knowledge."
One of the
How can it be lifted and taken away from
us? Meaning knowledge. Yeah.
>> And we recite it. Recite the Quran.
>> We teach it to our children and our
family.
May your mother disown you.
Medina. I took you as one of the most
knowledgeable in Medina.
This is the Torah and the with the Jews
and the Christians.
>> So he says it's with them, right?
>> One second.
>> What is of it of benefit to them,
>> right? So why?
>> So they have the Torah gospel, right?
This is in Islam a hadith. One hadith.
>> Oh, no. I showed you two.
>> Yes. The wisdom of it. Even when you
connect it with that one, do not believe
those people. What is left?
>> I don't care about the people.
>> So following the commandment of Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam from the
previous hadith.
>> According to the according to Muhammad,
did they have the Torah gospel with
them?
>> That what is called there?
>> No, it doesn't. Oh, so that means the
Quran was corrupted. No respond there,
right? I'm not done with the hadith.
>> Yeah. But according to the hadith, did
they have the Torah and Gospel with
them?
>> Not the same. Not the same.
>> Not what do you mean not the same?
>> Not the same.
>> Not the same. What?
The pre-erequisite
information is already revealed to
Muhammad in [laughter] the Quran.
>> WHAT DOES THAT GOT TO DO WITH I'M ASKING
YOU, BRO?
>> Because this is an explanation of the
Quran.
>> So, do you believe Muhammad or not?
>> So, just like just like there are people
living today, right? The only thing they
know about Islam, right, is that they
say I'm Muslim and like you wear a cross
on your chest, right? They wear Allah on
their neck, right? And they don't pray.
They don't recite. They don't know
nothing, right? That knowledge and the
benefit from that knowledge is lost to
them even though the Quran is there,
>> right?
>> But so they have the Torah gospel,
right?
>> We know that at this point when this had
all of them, they got the Torah.
>> No, they don't.
>> So you don't believe Muhammad?
>> I do. It's okay. So he
>> prerequisite is that he already
explained
it and they put a lot of
>> Okay. So Muhammad is saying that the
change book is the Torah.
>> The other hadith, he mentions it.
>> Y'all don't believe Muhammad. Y'all hate
Y'all hate Muhammad.
>> I'm defending Muhammad. Look, I love I'm
on team Muhammad.
>> I love my own parents.
>> No, you don't.
>> More than I love my children.
>> So you put you nor I love my wife.
>> So you don't believe what your parents
say?
>> Because I love every single person on
earth.
>> Then why don't you believe what he says?
Why don't you believe what he says?
>> I do. I take everything he says in
context. because they have everything.
So, Michelle, when he says,
when he says that they have the Torah
and they have the I got you, but hold on
a second. When he says that they have
the Torah and the Gospelith, is Muhammad
telling the truth, yes or no?
>> Let's read the find.
>> You already read it.
>> No, I read halfway.
>> So, the part where he says the Torah and
the Gospel are with the Jews and
Christians. Is he telling the truth?
>> The corrupted Torah and the corrupt
gospel is
>> Is he telling the truth?
No answer again.
>> They don't they don't they don't listen
to Muhammad. They hate it. They hate
Muhammad.
>> So
mentioned I found
>> Did you hear Did you hear the
>> hadith? Which one?
>> The one I read. Bro,
>> I heard that already.
>> So you heard that it said that Muhammad
said that they have the Torah.
>> You've been on the subject for an hour
and a half, bro. We got to transition
into Trinity. Now you brought a new new
question. Why? WHY YOU LET HIM TALK
ABOUT Islam the whole time, brother? You
got to get back and ask about theology
as well.
>> So no answer.
I want to talk about the Trinity.
>> Did they have the Torah go?
>> I got to look into that. I got to look
into that. You You know how it goes,
Avery. Somebody ask you a question. You
got to look into it. I want to talk
about the Trinity. [laughter] That's
what I'm talk about. Cuz you've been
here talking about this for an hour and
a half. Real quick, my iPad. I promise.
>> Okay. Where's your iPad?
>> I want a quick time out real quick. I
want to ask you something real quick.
So, this brother right here, I don't
know his name, but we we got into a
little back and forth at the booth over
there.
>> Leaving here because this is a little
commercial break. Commercial break. No.
No. THIS IS IMPORTANT. THIS IS I'm not
>> just just I just want to say close it
out.
Just quick question. Do you guys Do you
guys Do you guys Hold on. We're about to
wrap it up.
>> All right. Wrap it up. Wrap it up. Wrap
it up. We're going to wrap it up. You
have this discussion.
>> We believe in everything our prophet
sent. You're taking [laughter] something
disingenuously cuz you know I'm trying
to ask David based upon exactly what was
mentioned in the previous that
was mentioned. They called it the Torah.
>> They called it the Torah.
>> Did Muhammad call it the Torah?
>> Do not believe.
>> No. No. Did Muhammad call it the Torah?
>> So when they have what they have,
>> Michelle, stop the fluff. Did Muhammad
call it the Torah? Okay. So did Muhammad
call it the Torah?
>> What they have, right? What they have
and what they call just like I followed
the same way. And I mentioned
experience.
>> I don't give.
>> No, he's not answering the question.
>> That's the problem. [laughter] What are
you going to call it? He already called
them corrupted.
>> Did Muhammad himself call it the Torah?
Did he call it the Torah and gospel?
>> That it is corrupted.
>> Did Muhammad call it the Torah and
gospel says that they threw it behind?
gospel?
>> But it is not the same thing you have to
do.
>> Okay. Thank you. Did Muhammad call it
the Torah gospel?
>> Avery. It's not that what you have.
>> Okay. Did he call it the Torah gospel?
>> Thank you. Hey guys, let's clap it up,
man. He said yes.
>> Finally, bro. It doesn't matter because
he already explained
let them land and then it'll be my turn.
Not because they don't follow what is
dragging the top. It's like
>> but they have to
>> Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala revealed to
them and they took out of context. If I
tell you now right and I ask you
something that is in here you can't even
verify for me for me.
>> Your Quran doesn't so I don't need to.
>> Who said what is said?
>> Your Quran says Allah said it. I don't
need to. No meaning in my Quran.
>> See we'll go to that next. Allah said
what? You don't believe in Islam though?
Yes. Yes. Matter of fact Allah said what
Muhammad said. You want to see that?
>> Who's Luke?
>> Allah said what Muhammad what Paul said.
You want to see that?
>> Who's Luke?
>> Do you want to see where Allah quotes
Paul?
>> No. I'm talking about Luke. Okay. Luke.
>> Well, Luke Luke is a companion of Paul.
>> He is a companion of Paul.
>> Yeah. Do you want to see where Allah
quotes Paul?
>> So right now when Luke says [laughter]
he don't want to see that you don't want
to see that question. Okay.
>> To draw an account of the things that
have been fulfilled
>> among us just as they were handed down
to us by those
>> from the first eyewitnesses. How many
generations are there between them and
the first eyewitnesses?
>> Oh no. I'll tell you this right here.
Watch this. You know how in Sarah Miriam
how you earlier was talking about
Zechariah.
>> This is a jump.
>> No, it's not a jump.
>> I'm asking you.
>> Remember you asked me about who's Luke
and did Allah quote Luke, right?
>> No, I didn't ask you if Allah quote
Luke. Jesus is my Lord and Savior and
have mercy on your soul. You literally
said that
>> brother this is recorded. This is going
to be better.
>> Jesus had a lot of
>> So look when you when you
quoting Luke
>> cuz you said I said that.
>> No.
>> What are you saying?
>> Look, I didn't say anything about Allah.
You know where Luke is.
>> I said Allah quotes him.
I said it before and then you said
that's why you came here.
>> You said Paul said and Luke and Luke
don't want it. How many generations are
there?
>> He said we heard it from Jesus a
Christian who heard it from heard from
many have undertaken to draw
a Christian among us meaning him and
others.
>> Keep reading by those. The first were
eyewitnesses and servants.
>> So eyewitnesses they wrote down and took
account who are they and who are they?
>> The disciples. Now I witness.
>> Now now let me say what I was about to
say.
>> So these
>> Let me say what I let me say what I was
about to say.
>> These are two this name because he's
mentioning go to Matthew chapter 10. It
gives you their names in the first five
Jesus though he had a guy.
>> So So watch this. So look this is this
is why this is all important. Okay. The
reason why all of this was important is
because y'all's argument so far has been
that the Jews and the Christians did not
have the Torah gospel and what we have
is some corruption. My point to you was
in the Quran,
>> brother. He does not.
>> He does.
>> Okay. My whole point was is that
according to Muhammad,
>> according to Muhammad, you have to
believe in the Torah and Gospel, not
simply that it was revealed once upon a
time, but you have to believe in it the
same way you believe in the Quran.
That's what he said. No, that's what he
said. I believe that there was a Torah.
>> Michelle, I didn't I didn't interrupt
you, bro. Y let me Y let me get mine
off. You got you got to let me get him
off. Come on guys. Let's all be
friendly.
>> You're asserting.
>> Okay. So friendly with this guy.
>> Stay friendly. Stay like Jesus.
>> Stay like Jesus.
>> Jesus.
>> Hey, we love Jesus.
>> So So with this being said,
>> a curse in our religion
>> when you said that Muhammad never said
that they had the Torah and Gospel with
them and then I showed you verbatim.
Muhammad says the Torah and the Gospel
are with the Jews and Christians the
same way that the Quran is with the the
Muslims. Yet knowledge was taken from
the Jews and Christians. It didn't avail
them to have the Torah gospel. In the
same way, even though they have the
Quran, it's knowledge is going to be
taken away.
>> It will be,
>> right? So, so who Allah, I guess, who
who cares? No. The point is people do
what? That's not the point. The point is
is that according to Muhammad, they had
the Torah, they had the gospel, and
Muslims had to believe in what they had.
So, but what you're doing? No, you
don't. Because what you're doing is
you're going against what Muhammad said.
You don't believe in the Torah. You
don't believe in the gospel. You think
it's corrupted. So I guess Muhammad is
telling us to believe in corrupted
scripture.
>> I'm on team Muhammad, man. I'm team.
I
supposed to
Arabic. English. [laughter]
my brother right here. [laughter]
>> It's over. Turn the cameras off.
>> It's over. [laughter] Leave our brother
alone. Get one of us later.
>> The difference is when I look at the
Quran today, I can prove without the
shadow of a doubt. Every single word in
it came from the mouth of Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
>> No, you can't profane inonation of sound
that he said it. Hey, somebody called
Tony and tell him to bring the haps the
wor.
>> I can recite.
Alhamdulillah.
>> Oh, that's beautiful. So, you know all
the different Quran.
>> So, right now those came down verbatim
from the mouth of Allah as they are
recited today. Every single authentic
one came down as was recited by.
>> So every single
>> that is every authentic
authentic. So is
>> just like the hadith have those things
that a liar tried to add or someone with
a weak memory tried to say we have those
preserved to have that integrity to know
the truth of the false. So is it so is
it possible that some have lies
>> even then do something false
>> even no even then right because all of
the Qurans amongst us today are verified
because of the millions of people who
memorize it by heart
>> so so when
so when Alabari says that one reading is
more correct than another is he wrong
>> Avery one one talk at a time
>> we are you said they're all equal
>> all of the that are all the Qurans why
you follow his tricks man What do you
mean another subject? One second. One
second.
>> We are We're on another subject. Yes. He
brought this up.
>> Question. Quick question. [laughter]
Another subject. And
when when Alabari says,
>> when Alab says that there's one Quran
reading that's more correct than the
other Quran reading, that shows that not
all Qurans are are correct. Right.
>> No jumping. One second.
>> No jumping. [laughter]
>> I just got to ask a question. Everyone,
>> we believe what we believe in the Quran.
>> Are you Muslim?
>> Huh?
>> You Muslim? I'm not a part of this.
>> OH YEAH. [laughter]
YOU WANT to you want to hack [laughter]
every single word right in the Quran
that is authentically the Quran and the
explanation of it from the hadith as
Allah subhana t commanded us to follow
right those righteous generations that
commanded us to follow him his
companions and those righteous
generations that ideology and
methodology and understanding we have
preserved Objectively, I can follow it.
But what you have is a bunch of what
ifs, ands, and maybe. And who is this?
Who is that? And extrapolations. Who
Who's Khalif?
>> Extrapulations.
>> Who's Khalif?
>> Khalif is one of the people that were in
one of the
>> Yeah. But who is he? What's his
granddad's name?
>> I don't personally.
>> OH, ALL THE WHATIFS. [screaming] AND YOU
DON'T KNOW WHO THEY ARE.
>> YEAH. Just like I can pull up who Luke
is, who Paul is, who Matthew is, and all
this kind of stuff. None of that
matters. I already told you who he is. L
Luke was a was a Greek physician and a
companion of Paul. So notice I just told
his name is Luke. What do you mean? So
now so now watch this. So when you say
let me respond
no jumping.
>> I'm not jumping. Okay. So let me say let
me respond to what you said. Let me
respond what you said. Okay. So when you
say that all the Quran
>> is a surah of
>> is it who?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Correct. You're absolutely
correct. Can I hear one?
>> I can validate I can validate and I can
go to the source and I can make sure I
can because even what you I got cut off.
I didn't get to say my point. You made
>> I didn't even get to get my assertion
out yet.
>> You did because you're taking away all
of the other places.
>> Can I say what I got to say please?
>> Where Allah mentions that the Quran.
>> How do How do How do How do How do How
do How do How do How do How do How do
you say please in Arabic? Quran say
please
>> and that's the
change please let me let me say you're
saying your language I don't [laughter]
have please
>> you know you know when is right
>> no what is that
>> you don't know what is salah
>> no is that like a type of prayer or
something
at the sunset we have to pray so we have
maybe 10 minutes right we can transition
can can I say my last thing and then
>> we can transition my question because
what you SAID WAS YOUR LAST I DIDN'T
EVEN GET to say it
>> you [laughter] said you said that Allah
never said that the Torah and the gospel
the people
>> Oh never said they changed it that's
never said they that's yeah he never
said that wait let me let me finish
Michelle so if you're saying that all
the all the Qurans are equally valid
Allah said them all verbatim that
there's all the speech lining all goes
back to Muhammad what is it what is it
But so here's the problem. According to
your scholars, you have an authentic
Quran reading and another cor uh uh
authentic Quran reading and Alabari
would say that one reading is more
correct than the other. That means that
they're not equal. They're not the same.
And either Allah made a mistake when he
said one of those. So when he talks
is one of the earliest of I know he's
one of the best
>> and he has all of what was said about
every single and every single thing and
most of what is in it is that which was
weak even though he
>> So why does he say one is more correct
than another if they're all equal
>> you that is what he said based upon the
information he had.
>> Exactly. Is he wrong made a mistake?
either he made a mistake.
>> What someone said
>> that's tough because No, he said no. He
said he said this is his opinion. I'll
jump.
>> He he he I need to see the whole thing
in context, not what you're saying out
there in a limb. I told you whatever is
authenticated from the
>> You going to learn to trust me, bro.
>> Allah subhana wa ta'ala revealed. We
don't take from our own opinion. We
follow what was sent down from the
>> But no, but but notice everything that I
gave you so far. Everything I said,
every single thing that I said, I was
able to pull up and show you verbatim
what I'm saying. So, what I'm saying is
is that when I when I bring up a hold on
when I say when I tell you I'm bringing
up a source, I can pull up anything you
want me to pull up and it's going to say
exactly what I'm saying. And then you're
going to have to make an excuse for like
Tabar was wrong. You just had
>> I just took two Hadith verbatim.
>> You didn't pull up anything.
>> What are you talking about?
>> That's a Christian video. That's a
Christian video.
>> What? Oh, I didn't pull up that two. I
didn't pull up two hadith.
>> That video about the is a Christian
video taking something out of context
without full information.
>> I'm talking about the hadith that I
pulled up. The hadith you brought two
hadith
>> from Bkari and Jeremy, right?
>> One that right?
>> One that sallallahu alaihi wasallam
literally verbatim mentioned not to take
the word basically of the people of the
book. But to believe in the book to to
believe what was sent down to them.
>> Exactly. We don't believe there was a
Torah. We believe there's an we don't
believe that what you have today is a
>> we don't believe even that what was sent
down to the
>> Yes. And you're going against Muhammad.